-You look fantastic, buddy.
You always do.
-You kept the beard.
-I did keep it.
I kept the beard.
-You love it
because everybody's saying
you're so hot right now.
[ Laughter ]
-Stop.
No, that's not why I love it.
-And you don't want to lose it.
The last time I saw Jimmy
was in front of a lemonade stand
with our kids...
-Yeah.
-...and I was like, "Oh, okay.
So this is a new look."
And then I hear that everybody's
saying how hot he looks.
And I notice it's still on.
-No, I just kept it on.
I figured --
I'm just gonna keep it on.
I have nothing --
I figured -- I don't know why.
-You've pruned it.
-No, I didn't prune.
-Really?
You didn't topiary your face?
-No.
This is a non-pruned beard.
Look at this.
-That's au natur?
-That's --
Yeah, that's how patchy it is.
-No scissors
have gone to this beard.
-Zero.
Where would I put scissors?
-I don't know.
Just a little number two.
-No, that's why it's almost
coming in
like a goatee
a little bit weird.
[ Laughter ]
But it's not.
I didn't --
I didn't do any trimming.
This is all legit.
-Am I right, though,
that we think maybe --
I think this is a good look.
Like, you're into it
and you're feeling it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't know.
I think something has to change.
I just think maybe --
You know what it was?
I saw Dolly Parton.
I went to the Smoky Mountains.
I did something with Dolly,
and I went --
-Dollywood -- you know,
your wife and I got lost
after we were road-tripping
around America in an RV.
I can't recommend it more.
You get to do
whatever you want to do.
You like a place, you stay.
You leave, hoo!
[ Laughter ]
And we went to Dollywood,
and we drove around for like
five hours
in the Smoky Mountains.
And you know
when you're road-tripping,
you kind of --
you know, five hours,
you're ready to call it a night.
And we pulled right back,
and we were like,
"Let's just pull over
and sleep for the night."
We go to pull over,
and we go to
right where we left
five hours ago.
It was like...
[ Laughter ]
It was like Winnie the Pooh's
loop or something.
And I was like,
"The Bermuda Triangle
is in the Smoky Mountains!"
[ Laughter ]
-"We can't leave this place!"
Yeah.
But how magical was that?
-Oh, but Dollywood was awesome.
And Dolly Parton --
I mean, come on!
Legend!
-So I felt like I should be
a Smoky Mountain man, a mystery.
And so it inspired me
to just grow a beard.
-Did Dolly see the beard?
-No.
She inspired me for the beard.
-Okay.
-Do you think Dolly
will enjoy the beard?
-Well, I think we need to know
because everything
Dolly likes is awesome.
-Yeah, true, yeah!
[ Laughter ]
I want to talk
to you about this.
'Cause you had a crazy summer.
I didn't really
get to catch up with you
when I saw you last week.
But I want to talk about
a couple things.
First of all,
you went to a wedding.
Okay?
-Oh, yes.
-Yes, you went to
Britney Spears' wedding.
-Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at this.
There's you, Madonna,
Selena Gomez, Donatella Versace,
Paris Hilton.
What -- How long
have you known Britney?
-Some serious O.G.
ladies right there.
-That is a good
gang of girls there, yeah.
-I -- you know,
I made friends with Britney
about a year and a half ago.
And we've sort of had
some secret exchanges.
And I know
that sounds nefarious.
-Yeah.
-It was exactly the opposite.
It was very connective
and honest.
And we've both been through
a lot of things.
We have some parallels that are
unique in their circumstances,
but, also, I think the things
that we go through in life,
although these circumstances
may seem so next-level,
the feelings of growing up,
struggling,
all the stuff
that we've both gone through,
is something that I felt
connected to her.
And I'm not a real
reach-out kind of person.
You know, I'm not Hollywood Bob.
I'm not slick.
I just -- the humanity
in what she was going through,
trying to get her freedom back,
was something
I felt compelled to reach out.
And we found
a deep connection there.
-Yeah. Good for you.
I'm glad you reached out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And --
-It's tricky, you know?
It's insane.
When you see everyone's life,
you go, "Oh, wow.
They must have a --
They must have a great life."
No one really knows anything
unless you --
and she was crying for help.
-Yeah. Yeah.
There is a human being
at the center of this.
And so, we made friends --
like, genuine friends.
-And did you have fun?
-And then I got invited
to her wedding, which could not
have been more intimate.
The people you see in that photo
are some of
the only people there.
There's only a few more.
At the actual event,
it was intimate.
It was fairy-tale-ish.
It was very sweet.
It was --
There was no press.
It was the way
she wanted to do it.
-Yeah, good.
-Which was really --
also led to that photograph,
which was also a moment.
None of us planned for it.
It just happened organically.
-When was this --
When was this dance party?
-Oh, then, that was later.
I also thanked her for not
having a sit-down dinner.
God, do I hate sit-down dinners!
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking about?
-Guess what --
we all got dressed up.
We all wanna dance,
and we wanna hang out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, you sit down, you eat.
No, no.
-What?!
-No, you're eating.
-Now I have to sit down.
And they always separate you,
like, "We're gonna force you
into a new social endeavor."
[ Laughter ]
The person you came with
that you want to hang out with
is over there.
[ Laughter ]
Why did you do that?!
And now let's eat
some bizarre food...
-Yeah.
-...that you didn't choose,
and -- and -- and I hate it!
-Sorry, sorry.
So, she got --
They did the ceremony.
She got
right to the dance party.
We had the best time,
and I was like, "Thank you!"
-Yeah, Britney!
We love you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do love Britney.
-I hate sit-down dinners.
-And then --
We won't ever do one.
-Unless it's a dinner party.
Then that's
a different situation.
-We've had sit-down dinners
before.
No, really lunches.
-But you know how weird I am
about the places.
Like, we like to go to this
one place 'cause you can
walk around in it.
I don't like that formal,
stuck to the chair
like I'm in the 1800s.
I don't -- I just --
When I go out, also, I finally
feel like I've got a feather.
Like, I've left the house.
The last thing I want to do
is sit and eat.
I feel social.
Let's party!
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know how to party.
By the way, look at you,
super model,
at the Dolce & Gabbana
fashion -- in Italy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you kidding me, Drew?
Drew Barrymore,
you're unbelievable.
By the way --
-I feel so awake now.
I mean, I wear only sweatpants
with hole-riddled
vintage T-shirts.
Like, I don't put a lot of
effort into myself in real life.
I don't.
I'm very shlubby.
And so it's nice,
after the pandemic and two kids
and a real body change, like,
I just really lost myself
for a lot of years,
and it's really nice
to try and put back in,
put a little effort in
every once in a while.
-Yeah!
You always --
I didn't know you --
I know, but when --
Come on.
This is just --
I dress like Jeff Spicoli
from "Fast Times
at Ridgemont High."
[ Laughter ]
That is my daily attire.
-Yeah.
-So, if you're, like,
at work, at the park.
-And going for it.
-Yeah, just put
a little energy into it.
-Did you get to celebrate the
40th anniversary of "ET" at all?
'Cause I know it was a big deal
this year.
-It was such a big deal.
And my daughters and I
were planning
to go with Steven, and it was --
Spielberg, not to name-drop.
I feel so bougie.
That wasn't the point.
-I think you're allo--
Of all people,
I think you're allowed to --
-"ET," Steven.
-Yeah, you're allowed.
-The wonderful Steven Spielberg.
And we're all so close,
and he knows my kids,
so he was like,
"Let's make sure the kids go."
And I was like, "I'm gonna watch
'ET' with you and the kids,"
and Grauman's Chinese
Movie Theatre
where my grandfather's,
their great-grandfather's face
is in the cement.
And, you know, I was...
♪ It's the circle of life ♪
-Yeah, yeah.
-And we have
planned it for months.
We're so excited.
It's probably one of
the biggest,
most important things
that we've ever experienced.
Only the day before, they both
test positive for COVID.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And I have to call Steven.
I'm shell-shocked,
and we didn't get to go.
So, we're doing a make-up
with hot-fudge sundaes
and in his screening room,
which is awesome.
-Have they seen "ET" yet?
-Yes. Yes.
They -- They --
They love it.
But it wasn't like watching it
in a movie theater
with Steven Spielberg.
-Yeah.
-And we were opening
the Turner Classic
Film Festival.
We were gonna sit and do
a sit-down interview
on the stage
with Ben Mankiewicz.
It was this thing
I've looked forward to so much.
So, everything happens
for a reason.
-Frankie's probably
around your age, right?
-A really exciting story
with no climax.
[ Laughter ]
-Not "ET."
"ET" was a great climax.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not gonna spoil it.
But Frankie is 7?
That's how old you were.
-She's 8.
8 1/2.
I was 6 when I filmed it,
7 when it came out.
-Oh, really?
-I've been doing this
such a long time.
-Wow! You've been doing it.
You've been doing it
such a long time.
-You know what's so funny, too,
is like,
people literally are like,
"Oh, so 'ET' was the first?"
I'm like, "Oh, no.
Oh, no, no.
I started at 11-months-old,
Puppy Chow.
[ Raspy voice ] And then I went
on to do a whole lot more.
I did TV movies and commercials.
-[ Raspy voice ] Let me tell ya
what the business was like.
-I was in a feature film.
By the time I did "ET,"
it was old hat.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm saying?
So, that was not my first gig.
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah,
not your first rodeo there.
-I was a vet by then.
-Yeah.
Can we talk about the show,
"The Drew Barrymore Show"?
Today, by the way, you're back.
I missed you.
I wanted to --
I love your show so much.
-[ Normal voice ]
I love you so much.
-And I love you so --
You looked great.
It was so good,
and it was so interesting.
I love that you just
put yourself out there.
You had your ex-boyfriend,
Justin --
-Yes, Justin Long,
who I love so dearly.
And, you know, I --
When we first launched,
it's a big measuring contest.
[ Raspy voice ]
Who's your first guest?
-Yeah.
-You know?
Show me the big guns,
the big names.
-Yeah, who do you got?
-[ Normal voice ] And I was
like, "I want to ask
Cameron Diaz and Lucy Liu,
my dearest girlfriends who I did
'Charlie's Angels' with.
We've experienced
everything in life you can.
Travel, birth, life, divorce,
marriage, kids, you know --
-Everything.
-Everything!
And I'm so proud
of our endeavor.
And I think I'm trying to make
this show as personal as I can
as well as have it be
a daytime talk show.
And I think there's such a rich
conversation about our exes.
You know, where does
that friendship go?
Listen, if they're toxic,
get them out of your life.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But nothing to talk about,
have a boundary.
But if there was good,
rich history there,
how do we champion those people?
How do we have them in our lives
in an appropriate way?
He has this awesome, wonderful,
incredible partner,
Kate Bosworth -- by the way,
what an incredible woman
who would allow this to happen.
If she's not my hero,
I don't know who is.
-Yeah, she just said,
"Yeah, go for it.
Go and talk
and have the conversation."
-How do we...
-It was so good.
-...deal with our real lives?
I've been doing movies
and playing characters
and being
a part of storytelling,
which is so
incredibly universal.
Talk about "ET."
If that didn't open me up
to the kind of life
I want to have...
But ever since I had kids,
I've been wanting to know, like,
how do you live a life that
isn't just a movie, that's real?
And this has been
the best avenue and exploration
for me right now
to do this show.
-It was emotional to watch.
But you guys were -- you came --
You were at our wedding,
both of you.
-Yeah, by the way,
he was my boyfriend.
We were at the wedding.
That was my date.
I never cried so hard in my life
than Nan and Jimmy's wedding.
Like, it got really awkward.
-No.
-Like, it was too much.
You know?
-And we had a tiny,
small wedding.
-Very small.
But Justin and I were there.
-This is the picture
from our wedding.
This is...
[ Laughter ]
...Donatella, Madonna...
Everyone.
And Justin. Not bad.
-See, in storytelling,
you call that a payoff.
-Hey, the callback, yeah.
But, yes, I mean --
-That was emotional.
I loved seeing you guys together
because I know
how close you were and fun.
-Also, you can say, you know,
we have changed.
Here's where we are at
in our lives now.
Here's what you're up to.
I want to celebrate it.
He's in the best movie,
called "Barbarian."
It's gonna be a classic.
Does anyone here
like scary movies?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think it's the number-one
movie in the country right now.
-It is?
-Yeah. Officially, yeah.
-Oh, my God!
I'm so happy!
I had to watch it by myself!
It was a nightmare!
[ Laughter ]
-Is it scary?
-It's the scariest movie!
-Yeah.
-It's so good.
It just taps into
every layer of fear.
-All right, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's really destined
to become a classic.
How wonderful for him.
-Yeah, he's on tomorrow.
I will talk to him about this.
-Please do.
-Yeah, exactly.
Congrats again on the season.
Every morning,
"Drew Barrymore Show."
You better watch --
TiVo, set your DVRs.
-TiVo!
-Drew Barrymore, everybody.
Season 3 of
"Drew Barrymore Show"
premiered earlier today.
Drew and I are playing a fun
new game when we come back.
Stick around.
It's a good one.